a lyon comme partout dans le monde la
crise financière fait les gros titres
depuis quelques semaines la bourse
plonge le dollar et l'euro tremblent sur
leurs bases avec une conséquence l'or
devient la valeur refuge
derrière cette entrée discrète le plus
gros négociant en métal précieux de la
ville
en deux semaines l'agencé a déjà réalisé
l'équivalent de deux ans de chiffre
d'affaires gilles renard n'avait jamais
vu une telle hausse en trente ans de
carrière
le cours du lingot du 13 octobre 2008 au
premier fixing de londres exprimé en
euros tard à 1399 en août 2007 il était
à 15 kg soit 30 % d'augmentation en un
an
qu'est ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui ce client
est un très gros acheteurs d'or il ne
souhaite pas qu'on le reconnaisse
aujourd'hui plus aucune pièce en or
française n'est disponible qu'à cela ne
tienne il se rabat sur les pièces
étrangères
et ce n'est pas son premier achat
l'homme pense qu'avec la crise ce lors
gardera de la valeur
pourquoi vous acheter des pièces d'or
d'accord
une question de protection du patrimoine
par rapport à la délégation qui va un
jour vous allez vous réveiller avec
votre argent qui voudra dix fois moins
c'est important patrimoine ça va pour ça
aujourd'hui
mais ce jour-là il y a aussi des
vendeurs venus profiter de la hausse du
cours de l'or
ce couple a raclé les fonds de tiroir
est sorti les bijoux de famille haby
mais il ne souhaite pas non plus être
identifié
je suppose
les séances de la terre
dans la balance il y à 80 grammes d'or
mais le négociant ne va pas payer les
vendeurs tout de suite il va d'abord
fondre les bijoux et leur donne tout de
même une estimation du prix
le but sur les héroïnes d'un voyageur
tulle devant les enfants
les bijoux partent maintenant pour la
fonderie de lagence un lieu tenu secret
dans ce bac ce jour là il y en a pour
près de deux cent mille euros de bijoux
ils vont être transformés en un seul
lingots
avec la crise financière le métal
précieux déclenche les passions
partout dans le monde de nouveaux
pionniers s'improvise chercheurs d'or
comme au temps du far west et les vieux
démons ressurgissent la violence la
destruction est une catastrophe annoncée
pour l'environnement
[Musique]
nous partons pour la californie et plus
précisément pour a piqué à cinq heures
de route de san francisco c'est dans ces
rivières qu'avait eu lieu la ruée vers
l'or du 19e siècle depuis quelques mois
c'est à nouveau l'excitation
appliquée et le siège du club des new
forty niners le plus gros club de
prospecteurs d'or de californie
dave mccracken en est le président
fondateur il ya encore quelques années
il était sur la paille le nouveau cours
de l'or l'a remis en selle
c'est la meilleure saison qu'on ait
jamais vu le nombre de membres du club a
doublé en un an le prix de l'or n'arrête
pas de monter et beaucoup de gens sont
intéressés ce week end dave mccracken a
organisé une session d'initiation pour
les prospecteurs d'or en herbe une
trentaine de personnes venues des quatre
coins des états unis ils ont payé 100
euros par tête pour apprendre à devenir
riche
bienvenue à tous pour cette quatrième
session de l'été
laissez-moi vous livrer un secret pour
trouver de l'or il faut le mériter pas
le choix il faut travailler dans la
salle un homme est encore plus attentif
que les autres robert rennais arrive de
san francisco il n'est pas venu en
touriste
quand le prix de l'or a monté c'est là
que j'ai été vraiment intéressé
maintenant qu'il est à 21500 euros le
kilo vous n'avez même pas besoin d'en
trouver beaucoup pour faire fortune
dans la vie robert la nef et le dj dans
les bals populaires pas de quoi devenir
millionnaire pour acheter en face à
maison à l'âge de 40 ans il compte sur
l'or mais d'abord il faut apprendre
[Musique]
vous allez devoir renifler l'or comme
ces chiens là
vous voyez ce que je veux dire
le groupe se déploie sur l'une des
nombreuses concessions qui appartiennent
à dave mccracken un ancien lit de la
rivière
les prospecteurs novice vont devoir
tester le sol à deux endroits différents
ça c'est la course dure il y a plein de
gravier dedans c'est ici que se trouve
lors
robert rennais découvrent la rue de
conditions du chercheur d'or un métier
de bagnard j'ai l'impression d'être un
prisonnier dans un pénitencier
pour isoler leurs robes et rennais ne
conserve que le petit gravier il apprend
ensuite le second gestes de base de tout
bon prospecteurs le lavage aux pannes
c'est cette grosse assiette creuse qui
sert à séparer l'or du sable
il faut que tu secoues le pann de droite
à gauche comme ça de petites pépites
apparaissent dès le premier test
mais c'est pas mal du tout c'est un
super panne
ça y est je suis riche j'ai touché le
filon c'est la chance du débutant moi
j'y crois à fond
robert est tellement content nuit qu'il
va montrer son exploit à dave mccracken
c'est un pas exceptionnel
exceptionnel
mais les tests que nous avons fait ici
sont tout aussi bons
et même meilleur
donc c'est ici qu'ont causera le filon
demain
un peu déçu robert mais tout de même
très excité
ça sent très bon pour demain
je pense qu'on va trouver beaucoup de
pépites
c'est ce que je prédis en tous les cas
[Musique]
le lendemain les piliers du club sortent
l'artillerie lourde des rampes de lavage
qui utilisent l'eau de la rivière grâce
à ces machines les prospecteurs peuvent
à miser beaucoup plus de terres en
quelques minutes tout le monde patauge
dans la gadoue
c'est marrant toi dans la boue
en l'espace d'une grosse après midi les
prospecteurs déverse plusieurs dizaines
de kilos de terre dans les rampes de
lavage mais robert et n'est lui ne voit
toujours pas de grosses pépites
elles sont toutes petites
92 hauts pour si peu d'or mais il y en a
beaucoup plus en dessous tu dois être
patient merci c'est ce que j'ai besoin
d'entendre
alors pendant que les autres chercheurs
d'or prennent leur mal en patience
robert haines et décide de mener sa
petite enquête auprès d'un autre
prospecteurs présents sur le site vous
avez dû utiliser combien de sous pour
arriver à ce résultat
à peu près
28 saut pour 10 grammes d'or
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
ça fait beaucoup de travail pour peu
d'or bon courage
ce n'est pas exactement ce que je
voulais entendre
c'est un peu décevant de voir tout le
travail qu'il faut fournir
fin de la journée c'est le moment de
revenir au club pour la répartition de
l'or entre les participants à rituel
solennelle 10 qui font sens
on a amassé 21 grammes d'or
c'est notre meilleure session on a battu
notre record
chaque participant reçoit sa part
l'équivalent de 20 euros
voilà ma part
robert est né le découvre sa nouvelle
maison n'est pas pour demain pourtant il
va rester encore quelques semaines
désormais accro alors
le seul ici qui touche gros c'est dave
mccracken le président du club
il s'est joué à la perfection la petite
comédie de l'or
je vais vous montrer un tout petit peu
de mon or
j'ai enterré le reste dans la forêt
dans ce coffre fort lors que dave
mccracken a racheté aux membres du club
à bas prix il est pas nue pour sa
retraite sans aucun complexe
avec lors que je possède déjà j'attends
d'arriver à 15 kg d'or et alors je
prendrai ma retraite
15 kilos d'or l'équivalent de 430 mille
euros
l'essentiel de ses revenus dave
mccracken les tirs des centaines
d'hectares de concessions qu'ils louent
aux membres du club les plus aguerris
c'est ici au fond de ces rivières que
l'on trouve ceux pour qui l'or est
devenu une religion
john coleman est cadre dans une banque
il vient ici tous les étés depuis des
années au club on le surnomme le
chanceux
alors sept mois qu'il ya environ 280
grammes d'or
cela représente 9000 $ qu'on a amassé en
deux semaines de travail
le filon est si bon que john cause
d'année sa femme ne travaille plus qu'à
mi-temps
ce qu'on touche ici ça nous permet de
vivre l'hiver sans travailler
et à au printemps on va aux philippines
rendre visite à la famille de ma femme
comme cela on évite le travail de bureau
à la con
avec la plus grosse pépite madame ces
mêmes fabriqué un joli pendentif
en cinq ans john cause d'année sa femme
ont sorti près de 80000 euros de leur
petit coin de rivière
d'autres prospecteurs du club ont moins
de chance et pourtant ils ont tout
abandonné pour vivre ici de vrais
pionniers à l'ancienne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi vous faites ça a payé comme ça
ils savent que c'est l'heure d'aller
bosser
lui c'est craig colts dit le nez
bonjour la planète le chercheur d'or le
plus expérimenté de la rivière
quant à mike sneijder c'est le meilleur
ami de craig il y a trois mois il
habitait encore à seattle ouvrier dans
le bâtiment le nouveau prix de l'or a
changé sa vie ça c'est mon chaton
il est un peu plus petit que l'ancien
j'ai déménagé pour venir ici j'ai
organisé une vente et jeux vendus tout
ce que je possédais
et me voilà
des pommes de terre dubé connaît des
heures et voici le troisième larron auto
gaiser retraité ancien combattant du
vietnam le cuisinier de la bande
le petit déjeuner des champions
depuis 10 ans récolte écume les rivières
d'alaska est d'ailleurs à la recherche
d'or avec le nouveau prix il a décidé de
revenir chez lui en californie
je devais rentrer en californie c'est
chez moi ici il y encore beaucoup d'aura
trouvé
il est huit heures du matin les trois
comparses partent pour le travail pour
eux c'est sept jours sur sept
ils partent pour cette concession qui
louent au club
[Musique]
tous leurs espoirs reposent sur cette
machine une drague
craig called et sa bande ont passé tout
l'hiver à la construire un gros
investissement
tout cet équipement nous a coûté
beaucoup d'argent le moteur le réservoir
tout ça ça nous a coûté près de
cinquante cinq mille dollars
je crois qu'on peut dire que c'est notre
bébé
avec ce gros tuyaux crec colts va
littéralement sucer le fond de la
rivière mike sneijder est chargé
d'écarter les grosses pierres
en tout sept heures d'un travail de
force sans compter les pierres qui se
coince dans le tuyau
les engueulades
lors ça se mérite
c'est beaucoup de travail
ça paraît compliqué de trouver le bon
filon
premier coup d'oeil de craig le nez sur
la rampe de lavage
décevant tout ce travail pour du gravier
aucune vraie pépite en vue
joue un peu d'or
mais il y en a beaucoup moins que ce que
je trouve d'habitude
depuis qu'ils sont arrivés il ya un mois
craig colt et sa bande n'ont pas trouvé
grand chose ils ont déjà brûlé toutes
leurs économies
de retour au camp le tamisage de l'or
commence une heure et demie d'attenté
fiévreuse comme tous les jours faire
fortune n'est pourtant pas la seule
raison de leur venue ici
j'ai fait tous les métiers du monde gt
soudeur j'ai été menuisier
j'ai même travaillé dans une animalerie
genou et c'est les poissons le corail et
tous ces trucs là
mais aucun de ces boulots n'arrivait à
l'auteur de la prospection d'or
elle ne paye pas toujours mais au moins
je suis libre
j'ai le cancer
j'ai des tumeurs ici un peu partout les
docteurs voulait que je reste à la
maison pour aller en chimiothérapie mais
pas question pour moi je reste ici
secret
j'aimerais pouvoir ramener à ses dehors
pour acheter un bout de terre par ici
comme ça on pourra continuer à chercher
de l'or
le tamisage se termine craig mike et
auto auront dégagés l'équivalent de 25
euros par personne juste de quoi payer
l'essence et la nourriture en plus ils
doivent reverser 10% pour la location de
la concession
même chez les prospecteurs d'or
professionnels rares sont ceux qui
décroche la lune
d'autres chercheurs d'or ont décidé
d'investir et d'acheter leur propre coin
de rivière la plupart des terres
appartiennent à l'état il suffit donc de
déposer un dossier pour obtenir une
concession renouvelable chaque année ça
coûte seulement 120 euros mais des
petits malins ont décidé de créer un
marché parallèle sur internet ils
revendent certaines concessions du
gouvernement en gonflant les prix avec
un argument choc
c'est là qu'on trouverait le plus d'or
les prix peuvent atteindre 100 mille
dollars un de ces sites est
particulièrement actif celui de charles
wilson il garantit aux acheteurs qu'ils
vont trouver de l'or chaque concession
aurait un potentiel aurifère reconnu et
un passé minier c'est écrit sur le site
nous avons pris rendez-vous dans les
bureaux de ce charles wilson l'homme est
justement en conversation avec un client
bien sûr que vous pouvez vendre l'or
vous trouvez sur votre concession malgré
les promesses apparemment le client n'a
pas encore trouvé d'or
on a installé notre rampe de la vase
mais on a eu beau travailler comme des
fous on n'a trouvé aucune pépite pour
l'instant ah bon
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il n'y en a pas
mais tu as concession s'appelle pas la
rivière de répond rien
salut
ce type là vient de becker ce fils
californie c'est une grande ville il n'a
aucune expérience
mais oui mais ça fait loto qu'ils
travaillent sur cette concession veut
lui avait vendu oui mais il n'a pas
encore trouvé le filon il ya encore un
an charles wilson travaillait dans
l'immobilier
avec la flambée du prix de l'or l'homme
à perfectionner la combine
voici toutes les concessions qui nous
intéresse
en bleu ce sont les concessions qu'on a
acheté
plutôt que d'acheter n'importe quel bout
de terrain charles wilson met la main
sur des concessions déjà exploités par
d'autres comme ça il est sûr qu'elle
possède un peu d'or et pour les
récupérer il joue sur la réglementation
la loi dit qu'il faut renouveler la
demande de concession chaque année il ya
une date précise pour cela et il faut
payer une taxe si vous ne le faites pas
n'importe qui peut racheter votre
concession
aujourd'hui justement il a repéré une
concession il rentre les coordonnées
géographiques sur le site du cadastre
américain le blm bingo
cette personne ne sait pas bien
enregistrer auprès du comté en fait elle
ne l'a jamais fait elle a payé sa
cotisation près du béal m et elle pense
que tous ses papiers sont en règle mais
si vous regardez au bas de cette page
il est bien écrit qu'il faut
s'enregistrer au béal m mais aussi
auprès du comté
et que vous avez 90 jours pour le faire
alors si vous faites pas les deux la
concession est remis sur le marché
avec l'aide de son assistant quelques
clics suffisent pour racheter le terrain
au cadastre ça ne lui coûte que 100 20
euros tant pis pour l'ancien
propriétaire étourdi mais c'est
complètement légal
ce sont les règles nous on s'en tient
aux règles
dommage pour elle quoi bah ouais elle
vient de perdre sa concession
allez rock'n'roll on va la localiser
cette concession
comme au bon vieux temps du far west
charles wilson se rend sur place pour
prendre possession de sa nouvelle
concession
[Musique]
alors voyons ça se trouve
c'est par là
la concession s'étend sur près de 8
hectares charles wilson dispose de tout
un attirail une bonne vieille pancarte
une bombe de peinture rouge et une
bouteille impossible pour l'ancien
propriétaire de contester si quelqu'un
vient il peut voir que nos papiers sont
parfaitement en règle et que la
concession nous appartient un simple
coup de peinture qui va lui faire gagner
beaucoup d'argent
cette concession va être ajoutée à
d'autres pour être vendus dans un lot et
donc on devrait en tirer au moins 48
dollar
une belle marge en perspective avec
quand même un petit risque celui de se
prendre un jour un coup de carabine
mais les vrais profiteurs de l'or se
trouve à quelques centaines de
kilomètres plus au sud au mexique dans
la sierra madre l'ancienne région
mythique de l'or espagnols ici plus
question de trouver quelques pépites les
méthodes sont industriels des dizaines
de petites entreprises fort le sous sol
à la recherche d'or si elles en trouvent
elles revendront la concession aux
grosses compagnies minières canadiennes
les leaders mondiaux
la rigueur storm dirige une de ces pme
de l'exploration depuis deux ans il
multiplie les carottages il doit
absolument trouver de l'or et vite
il ne faut pas seulement trouvé un peu
d'or et d'argent ce n'est pas suffisant
il faut la qualité et la quantité
mais si le projet réussi je deviendrai
millionnaire
la société de la rigueur storm est cotée
à la bourse de toronto elle dépend du
bon vouloir de ses actionnaires surtout
en cette période de crise financière
et aujourd'hui justement la rigueur
storm reçoit la visite d'un important
investisseur qui représente un fonds de
pension
l'homme arrive de toronto de son
appréciation dépendra la continuation du
forage
je suis là pour vérifier les données
techniques du site
et plus tard je pourrais donner une
évaluation du prix de leurs actions
[Musique]
première étape de la visite ce diaporama
qui présente les derniers résultats du
carottage à ce stade la rigueur storm
estime que sa mine contient un potentiel
de 56 tonnes d'or mais cela ne suffit
pas
j'aimerais vous poser une question
stratégique
là vous brûler un million de dollars par
mois c'est une belle somme
qu'en pensez vous pouvoir arrêter les
forages et proposer un business plan
viable mettons sur les 12 prochains mois
leisinger ce tome s'efforce de le
rassurer
si quelques mois on a prévu de sortir de
nouveaux résultats très intéressants sur
les ressources en or
savez c'est une grande compagnie veut
nous racheter aujourd'hui pas de
problème
mais avant que cela arrive on ne veut
pas s'arrêter de forêt si on s'arrête
aujourd'hui plus personne ne voudra nous
racheter
l'aris eggleston emmène alors chris
thompson sur l'un des projets de la
compagnie
en l'occurrence une ancienne mine d'or
espagnol achetés aux villageois d'à côté
pour une bouchée de pain le site est
impressionnant chris thompson se déride
un peu
vous êtes un peu comme harrison ford
dans la dernière croisade non
c'est vrai
frimpong c'est comme ça que mes
collègues m'appelle à toronto indiana
jones
mais sur le fond chris thomson restent
sceptiques du titre et qui consomment
c'est bien cette ancienne mine mais ce
qui excite vraiment le marché c'est
quand un projet est entièrement nouveau
une nouvelle mine
avec des centaines de tonnes d'or
dernière étape de la visite la plus
décisive la salle où sont entreposés les
carottes ce sont elles qui disent la
vérité de la ressource en or chris
thompson comparé les données papier aux
carottes qu'il voit en vrai il montre
enfin quelques signes d' enthousiasme
je suis maintenant convaincu que leurs
données sont bonnes et vérifier
sans voyons cette carotte je suis
maintenant sûre qu'il ya de l'or et
qu'il y en a beaucoup et
ça veut dire quoi vouloir donné qu'elles
notent
10 sur 20 15 sur 20 aux
18 ans
chris thomson repart maintenant à
toronto la rigueur store lui est plus
que satisfait il espère vendre sa mine à
une grosse compagnie minière d'ici à six
mois
mais là pas de leur fait aussi des
victimes
retour en californie et plus précisément
dans la région de fresno
nous roulons sur la route 49 la route
mythique des chercheurs d'or du siècle
dernier une région remplie de ville
fantôme et deux mines d'or abandonné
c'est ici qu'en juin 2008 trois jeunes
ont été découverts morts dans une
ancienne mine d'or un accident tragique
team et faustine à roche ont découvert
les corps il possède la ferme voisine
[Musique]
le plus jeune des garçons avaient rendez
vous avec une jeune fille en fin d'après
midi mais il n'est pas venu
la fille a débarqué le soir à la maison
nous on savait que le camion des jeunes
étaient toujours là
c'est là qu'on se dit que quelque chose
n'allait pas
les trois jeunes étaient arrivés le
matin même de la ville proche il voulait
trouver quelques pépites pour payer un
voyage à leurs copines
les garçons devaient être en train
d'essayer de sortir quand ils sont morts
ils étaient juste là au niveau de ce
ventilateur
il n'avait plus que quelques mètres à
faire mais ils sont succombé au monoxyde
de carbone
ça n'a l'air de rien mais la mine est
très profonde les jeunes ont brûlé tout
l'oxygène en quelques heures
j'ai pris une grande respiration pour
aller voir s'il vivait encore il y avait
six mètres à descendre
mais les jeunes étaient déjà morts
donc je suis remonté j'ai appelé les
urgences
départ et arrivée il était en larmes
vous pensez bien perdre deux fils d'un
seul coup
et des mines abandonnées comme celle ci
il en existe des dizaines de milliers en
californie notamment dans cette région
située plus au sud non loin du désert
mojave
peter grace travail pour le cadastre
américain le belem il est chargé de la
sécurité des anciennes mines
cet été il a décidé de patrouiller pour
empêcher les nouveaux chercheurs d'or
d'entrer dans les puits
picard fait gaffe il ya un puits devant
vous perche à
peter gray a beau sourire un homme est
mort le mois dernier en tombant dans
l'un de ses puits
ça serait mieux de revenir je ne sais
pas s'il est assez d'air là dedans
[Musique]
si le prix de l'or continue à monter
ça va devenir un vrai problème pour le
blm
par manque d'argent le belem n'a pu
fermer que 5% des anciens pluie alors la
seule parade de peter graves c'est de
faire de la prévention dans les clubs de
prospecteurs d'or du coin ici ils sont
des dizaines à venir chercher la pépite
malgré la chaleur plus de 30 degrés à
l'ombre
[Musique]
on a beaucoup de gens qui viennent nous
voir c'est sûr
nous blm on ne veut pas que des gens se
risque à aller dans les vieux puits pour
trouver un filon
mais c'est ce que je leur dis aux
nouveaux il me demande où sont les vieux
puis
il y en a un là bas mais moi qui viens
ici depuis 12 ans je ne me suis jamais
risqué
c'est trop dangereux oui c'est vrai
apparemment ici le message passe le plus
gros problème de peter grève c'est cette
vieille mine d'or
il a fait fermer le site reste la
pollution
la mine est infecté d'arsenic une
réaction chimique naturelle pour les
mines d'or est difficile et coûteux à
dépolluer mais là-dessus no comments
pourquoi vous n'avez pas fait dépolluer
le site
je ne peux pas répondre à cette question
c'est sérieux je ne peux vraiment pas en
parler
ils ont bien insisté sur ce point à la
direction de la communication c'est
parce que ça coûte trop cher
heureusement oui c'est ça mais je ne
peux pas en parler
l'arsenic le poison des mines d'or qu'il
apparaît lorsque l'autre pluies touchent
les déchets de la mine on appelle ça une
fuite d'acide
nous partons pour grass valley charmante
petite ville touristique à quelques
heures en voiture de san francisco ici
se trouvait la plus grosse mine d'or de
californie la mine de lempire pendant
100 ans des cohortes de mineurs ont
extrait des milliers de tonnes d'or et
enrichit les propriétaires la famille
borne aujourd'hui la mine est devenue un
parc national très prisé des touristes
et des habitants mais il ya un problème
ces enfants jouent à côté d'un cours
d'eau remplie d'arsenic et de métaux
lourds
en cause bien sûr la mine et des années
de pollution
ron manson dirige le parc il a dû faire
fermer le tiers de la zone aux visiteurs
santé publique oblige
[Musique]
les gens jouent avec la terre surtout
les enfants et qu'ils mettent leurs
doigts dans la bouche il ya une chance
qu'ils avalent des métaux lourds
c'est un autre gros problème c'est la
poussière fait des jours où il ya
beaucoup de vent daste ici les gens
montent à cheval ou foin jogging ils
peuvent aspirer de l'arsenic du plomb
pendant des années ces déchets non
déclenché aucune protestation de la part
des habitants il aura fallu la plainte
d'une ong pour que l'administration du
parc se décide enfin à lancer la
dépollution du site
alors sous cette drôle de prairies rhône
manson a fait enfouir les déchets les
plus toxiques une sorte d'immense
sarcophage en béton
mais les terrains aux alentours est
pollué et le risque de propagation est
très élevé
le grand problème c'est qu'on l'aude
puis rentrer en contact avec la terre
qui renferme des métaux lourds elles se
forment des rigoles qui partent dans les
petits ruisseaux
et donc ça va dans la rivière du wolf
creek qui traverse la ville puis dans un
fleuve qui se déverse dans la baie de
san francisco
pour l'instant ron johnson et ses
équipes en sont encore au stade des
études
la décontamination totale de la mine et
de ses rivières ne devrait être effectif
que dans une quinzaine d'années s'il
trouve l'argent d'ici là
[Musique]
mais il n'ya pas que les mines du siècle
dernier qui sont pollués nous nous
rendons dans le montana un des états
d'amérique qui possède de plus de mines
d'or
jim johnson dirige les ong locales
spécialisées dans la pollution des mines
il nous emmène survolé une catastrophe
écologique majeure
c'est la mine qui a été condamné à la
plus grosse amende jamais vue aux états
unis
32 millions de dollars pour avoir pollué
l'eau
nous survolons les petites montagnes
rocheuses du montana en direction de la
mine 2 of man land où ce qui
à sa création en 1979 elle prétendait
être la mine à ciel ouvert la plus
moderne du monde grâce à une technique
simple faire couler un produit chimique
sur la roche pour faire ressortir lors
le cyanide un produit soit disant
miracle mais dès les premières années
d'exploitation la compagnie canadienne
qui détient la mine constate un gros
problème du cyanide coule un peu partout
dans la nappe phréatique
sans compter les habituels rejets de
métaux lourds
la première fois qu'il ya une fuite
c'est un ingénieur de la mine qu'il a
constatée simplement rentré chez lui un
soir il a senti une odeur étrange dans
sa salle de bain et c'était l'odeur du
cyanide
aujourd'hui la plupart des roches dégage
des métaux lourds qui vont dans la nappe
phréatique
les gens qui habitent aux alentours ne
peuvent plus boire d'eau il a fallu
construire une usine de retraitement
jim johnson nous présente une des seules
photos de la fuite de cyanide on y voit
une rivière à la couleur orange ou toute
vie aquatique a disparu en réalité la
bâche sens et isoler la mine de la nappe
phréatique n'a jamais fonctionné
alors avec son ong jim johnson s'est
lancé dans une croisade il a accumulé
les preuves de dysfonctionnements comme
vous pouvez le voir la mine du golden
sun light la mine du beijing creek la
mine de bill mountain la mine de kendall
et cetera toutes les mines à ciel ouvert
du montana qui ont utilisé du cyanide
ont eu des fuites
cette technologie a échoué partout
en 2003 jim johnson a lancé un
référendum populaire avec succès toutes
les mines à ciel ouvert utilisant le
cyanide sont désormais interdites au
montana un résultat historique
depuis d'autres états américains ont
durci leurs législations
au mexique voisin on n'a pas les mêmes
scrupules
depuis quelques années des mines à ciel
ouvert utilisant le cyanide s'implante
un peu partout dans le pays nous partons
pour la ville de san luis potosi au
centre du mexique nous avons entendu
parler de cette mine située juste au
dessus d'un petit village s'éroder san
pedro
depuis dix ans entre la compagnie
canadienne qui détient la mine et les
militants écologistes c'est la guerre
internet sont fait l'écho
d'un côté ce spot réalisé par la mine
met en scène la nouvelle école la
plantation de cactus l'afflux d'argent
pour les habitants
de l'autre on voit d'énormes
manifestations les accusations de
catastrophe écologique mais ici pas de
référendum la mine prospère
[Musique]
nous avons obtenu l'autorisation de
filmer pour la première fois à
l'intérieur de la mine de s'éroder san
pedro
elle vient de rentrer en production
bazas ils veulent communiquer
[Musique]
ronda bénéteau est chargé de presse pour
la compagnie gold elle nous a prévu un
planning chargé
alors quel programme en date je vous
emmène faire une visite de la mine on va
aller au sommet voir l'extraction de
l'or et puis on va visiter le village
que l'on a reconstruit ailleurs
mais avant tout cela ronda veut nous
faire rêver en nous donnant accès au
saint des saints
ce bâtiment où sont entreposés les
lingots d'or double sas porte à
reconnaissance manuel la sécurité est
maximale le coffre-fort s'appelle même
le pentagone
et voici les fameux lingots de la
compagnie new gold ne vous y trompez pas
c'est bien de l'or mais de l'or mélangé
à de l'argent d'où cette couleur étrange
ça pèse 22 kg et ça vaut combien la shac
lingots représente 40 mille euros
ce jour là dans le coffre-fort il y a
près de 800000 euros ces lingots vont
être revendus à un fondeur qu'il
revendra ensuite à des grossistes avant
d'atterrir peut-être dans votre
bijouterie mais nous n'en saurons pas
plus
notre client est américain c'est tout ce
que nous pouvons dire
nous partons maintenant 4 4 en haut de
la mine
2200 mètres d'altitude
en allant de production la compagnie a
déjà éventré une bonne partie de la
montagne
tout proche nous apercevons le village
de s'éroder san pedro
ronda bénéteau passe le relais aux
ingénieurs mexicain pour les
explications techniques il pourrait
éclaircir un mystère aucune trace de
pépites autour de nous
et c'est ce qui est difficile c'est
impossible de voir l'or en fait on
obtient 0 5 gramme d'or par tonne
cela signifie qu'on doit extraire une
tonnes de rochers pour obtenir 0,5
gramme d'or
ça veut dire que pour obtenir ce
résultat vous devez raser la montagne
oui c'est ça tout ce matériel comme ils
disent ils en déblai chaque jour
plusieurs centaines de tonnes pour cela
la mine utilisent des explosifs
contenues dans ces sacs blancs 30 tonnes
de tnt en moyenne par jour
une dizaine d'explosions quotidienne à
seulement 400 mètres du village
[Musique]
une fois les rochers extrait de la
montagne ils sont apportées ici dans cet
immense champ de pierres nourri par un
ballet incessant de camions
tout un réseau de tuyaux est ensuite
déployé comme pour un chant d'irrigation
il déverse au compte gouttes un mélange
d'eau et de cyanide c'est ce produit
chimique qui doit faire ressortir lors
de la roche comme montana le précieux
métal et d'ensuite recueillis dans cet
immense bâche pour l'ingénieur aucun
risque de fuite
on fait très attention si une pierre
perce la bâche on la repère tout de
suite c'est donc le match il n'y a aucun
risque de fuite
la production a commencé il ya un an
pour l'instant aucune fuite de ciani n'a
été constaté
le lendemain nous partons pour le
village nous rendre compte par nous
mêmes
nous découvrons des touristes en
goguette des enfants en sortie scolaire
l'église reconstruite par l'argent de la
mine
a priori
tout est calme
[Musique]
mais à quelques centaines de mètres du
village nous remarquons une marre un peu
étrange
une grande mare rouge sang elle se situe
à deux pas du parking où se garent les
cars scolaires a priori elle ne contient
pas de cyanide c'est autre chose
pour savoir de quoi il s'agit nous
partons pour san luis potosi la grande
ville voisine
direction le centre d'études et de
conseil en systèmes environnementaux
marcos monroe il en est le directeur
pour lui le seul risque de pollution
classique ce sont de toutes petites
fuites d'arsenic à l'entendre rien de
très grave
ecritel ça peut arriver que des flaques
d'arsenic se forme dans une mine d'or
mais les risques sont réduits les
l'arsenic ne pénètre pas dans les nappes
phréatiques sont là chaque
week-end ou au mexique on a préféré
encadrer les mines d'or qui utilisent le
cyanide temps plutôt que de les
interdire a quittés
et moi justement j'ai participé à
l'élaboration des normes
environnementales mexicaine
sur ce type de mine
marcos monoï et tout particulièrement
chargé de surveiller la mine de s'éroder
san pedro nous décidons donc de l'année
sur place
sa réaction est éloquente il s'agit bien
d'une fuite d'arsenic mais elle est
énorme
dois dire que c'est impressionnant
impressionnant
cette coloration rouge que vous voyez
c'est un mélange de métaux lourds et
avec du fer et de l'arsenic et c'est
dangereux et bien sûr
c'est un enfant passe et qu'il touche la
flaque avec sa main position
et ensuite mettre sa main dans sa bouche
et alors ça m'a passé directement dans
son organisme évidemment ça finira dans
le sang
difficile pour mac os banderas et de
rester sans rien faire il nous promet
d'envoyer une équipe sur place dès le
lendemain à première vue cette pollution
n'émeut personne ici elle fait partie du
quotidien des villageois sur la grand
place se marchandent babioles connaît
tout le monde
la pollution c'est le prix à payer pour
donner du boulot à tous ces gens
si l'âme il s'en va il n'y aura plus de
pollution mais toutes ces familles
comment ils vont vivre
moi je peux vous parler librement parce
que je n'ai rien à voir la mine par
contre le monsieur qui à côté de moi il
travaille à la mine
s'il dit quelque chose qu'il ne faut pas
dire ou qu'ils aient mal interprété il
peut perdre son boulot et tout le monde
va lui tomber dessus c'est ça le
problème
comme lui 70% des villageois travail
pour la mine
mais un homme brise le consensus
mario martinez possède une petite maison
dans le village
il est ingénieur hydrologue à la tête du
front d'opposition à la mine le f à eau
les nuisances de la mine il connaît bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand même tu as vu il ya eu une
explosion
et les rochers qui ne contiennent pas de
hors
jeu les mettre là bas sur cette colline
c'est
après la mine elle même il restera 117
millions de tonnes de déchets
et c'est quoi le problème
ces rochers peuvent créer des fuites
d'arsenic surtout qu'il y à une rivière
là bas qui alimente les nappes
phréatiques de toute la région
mais manifestement le discours de mario
martinez passe mal dans le village sa
porte a été taguée par d'autres
villageois
t'as vu ils ont marqué nerfs des lieux
de merde
on voit que ce sont des enfants ils ne
savent même pas écrire
nous demandons à mario martinez de nous
conduire à l'entrée de la mine pour lui
c'est inhabituel il est sur ses gardes
et pendant que new line interviewons des
villageois le prennent pas parti
salle [__] j'ai de quoi m'occuper de
toi ici arrête de rigoler [__]
c'est les gens qui travaillent pour la
mine nous demandent ce qu'on fait ici
très vite la situation va dégénérer
c'est un lieu public ici j'ai le droit
d'être là
et qu'est ce qui se passe mario qu'est
ce qu'il fait ici
c'est quoi ton problème
et retire ta caméra toujours calmes et à
d'autres comme retire ta caméra
[__] de mario
regarder si j'ai de quoi de faire la
fête
bientôt le reste de la famille débarque
alors mario qu'est ce que tu fais ici tu
sais que tu ne dois pas venir ici
dit quelque chose à ma mère et je te
pète la gueule
la situation est explosive
nous décidons de baisser la caméra
avec mario martinez nous nous réfugions
dans notre voiture
excusez nous on ne voulait pas vous
agresser on a un problème avec ce
monsieur
ça a à voir avec le fait que ce monsieur
est contre la mine quand tu as de la
mine nous on ne font pas la mine on
défend les gens qui travaillent
cette femme accepte de nous parler elle
est institutrice dans la nouvelle école
fondée par la mine elle assume
totalement sa violence envers les
militants du ffs
politique à ces politiques c'est ces
gens là sont des activistes ils n'ont
jamais travaillé de leur vie
quand on éloigne la caméra elle évoque
même l'agression d'un avocat opposé à la
mine enrique rivera l'homme fait l'objet
d'un reportage sur internet il y raconte
que suite à son agression il avait dû
passer plusieurs jours à l'hôpital
enrique rivera est aujourd'hui réfugié
au canada l' enquête de police n'a
jamais rien donné
[Musique]
c'est la deuxième fois qu'on agresse
quelqu'un la première fois c'était avec
enrique rivero
elle nous sommes un jour il est venu ici
il s'est mis à gueuler sur mon neveu que
vous avez vu il lui a déchiré un papier
mon neveu s'est mis à genoux et henrique
rivera lui a marché sur la main allez au
micro n'y alors à ce moment là mon beau
frère est sorti et il ya eu une grosse
bagarre
au final ça a marché puisqu'il a quitté
le pays
ce fonctionnement
nous retrouvons mario martinez un peu
plus loin dans le village il a eu chaud
regarde regarde le coup de machette
qu'il m'en donnait
[Applaudissements]
regarde c'est là qu'ils ont bien coup de
pied
là ils ont lancé des pierres ils ont
aussi pété le pare brise
ces gens mais avant il était contre la
mine eux ils étaient contre la mine oui
en faisait même des réunions avec eux
disposent mélamine a commencé à leur
donner de l'argent à leur donner du
travail
ils ont changé de bord
[Musique]
ce jour là ces policiers n'ont même pas
interrogé les agresseurs mais mario
martinez va tout de même porté plainte
[Musique]
la compagnie minière at elle conscience
de ce climat de violence qui règne au
village depuis son arrivée nous
retournons à la mine mais cette fois ci
nous ne sommes pas les bienvenus ce
garde me demande de partir
nous rappelons ronda bénéteau souvenez
vous c'est la charge et de presse qui
nous avait fait visiter la mine elle est
repartie au canada depuis
bonjour comment ça va oui on a eu un
petit problème on off quoi donc on a
fait une interview avec un homme qui
s'appelle mario martinez et pendant
qu'on interviewait les villageois sont
venus nous attaquer avec des machettes
et même avec un revolver
attendez laissez moi passer quelques
coups de fil je vais voir ce qui se
passe je vous rappelle dans une demi
heure ok d'accord
nous devons quitter la mine
ronde à benito nous rappelle plus tard
dans la soirée
elle ne condamne pas vraiment les
agressions
on commence en avoir vraiment marre de
devoir nous justifier avec les dizaines
de millions de dollars qu'on a dépensé
pour reconstruire des maisons pour
fournir un médecin gratuitement aux
ouvriers
on attendait on a été bien plus généreux
que n'importe quelle compagnie minière
on en a vraiment marre de toutes ces
conneries
à s'éroder san pedro la mine n'est pas
près de s'arrêter
au troisième trimestre 2008 ces vendeurs
ont augmenté de plus de 17%
[Musique]
au terme de notre enquête en plein coeur
de la sierra madre mexicaine nous avons
croisé sur la route un homme qui incarne
à lui seul la folie de l'or il ya 20 ans
jazz et brosse qui était le premier
américain à venir chercher de l'or ici
mais dans les années 90 le prix du métal
jaune a plongé il a tout perdu ruiner et
pourtant aujourd'hui à l'âge de 65 ans
il y retourne c'est plus fort que lui
vous allez voir demain notre mine elle
était très développé en fait c'était une
jolie petite mine mais elle ne dégageait
pas assez d'argent à l'époque
jazz et brosse qui a repris le volant de
sa vieille chevrolet pour revoir la mine
trois jours de route depuis denver
colorado à affronter le désert les
torrents et les orages
cette mine il aimerait bien la rouvrir
alors aujourd'hui c'est une tournée
d'inspection
le matériel date de mathusalem tous les
fils de cuivre ont été pillés par les
villageois
mais jay croient encore que sa mine
possède un vrai potentiel
regardez la mine est bien conservée
rouvrir cette mine c'est le moyen de
rattraper le temps perdu de gommer
toutes ces années de galère
je me sens tellement triste de voir tout
cela
après ton de travail étant de 100 sur la
chance de bien finir par tourner wirtgen
7000 ne doit pas mourir
comme jay ils sont nombreux à tout miser
sur l'or à paris fragile car les
statistiques sont implacables
au mexique seul un projet sur 1000 tient
ses promesses et eldorado
[Musique]